t boone pickens has always been a man in
motion from his childhood onwards he has
shown a remarkable ability to identify
important goals that achieved them at
levels no one else had imagined and he
shows an equally remarkable ability to
constantly grow and adapt to a changing
world in 1954 he founded Mesa petroleum
with 2,500 dollars and with his
extraordinary optimism in daring he soon
grew it into America's largest
independent oil and gas company then in
1997 when many people might have gladly
retired he went on to found BP Capital
Management which became the nation's
most successful energy oriented
investment fund and please note that the
beep he stands for boone Pickens not
that other BP it's a company with an
unrivaled ability to anticipate future
energy trends mr. Pickens has been
repeatedly praised as one of the most
effective CEOs of all time and indeed in
1989 was picked by financial world as
the CEO of the decade now for all these
reasons mr. Pickens has enormous
credibility in thinking about our
nation's energy future in 2008 he
launched the Pickens plan a bold
initiative to reduce our dependence on
foreign oil in particular OPEC oil he's
shown how we could reduce that
dependence by thirty percent in ten
years by using our abundant assets and
natural gas and wind and he spent more
than 80 million dollars of his own money
promoting that plan his proposal has
received support from truly the widest
spectrum of political figures imaginable
ranging from the president of the Sierra
Club to President Obama to mark sanford
former governor of South Carolina and
almost two million US citizens have
signed up as supporters and perhaps more
important to many here in this room this
plan was recently very well received on
the daily show with jon stewart it is
therefore really no surprise that into
9 because of his forceful advocacy for
this energy program he was picked by
Time magazine as one of the hundred most
influential people in the world now as a
nation we all need to recognize the
urgency of confronting our current
energy situation and planning for the
future and we all owe an enormous debt
to mr. Pickens for putting forth a
highly concrete and creative proposal
that is both green and feasible in
addition it's a plan that could
radically transform international
relations so that we are no longer feel
compelled to make distasteful alliances
with other countries because of our
addiction to foreign oil mr. Pickens has
offered us a way forward that raises the
very real question of why aren't we
acting more forcibly right now to
address this crisis and yet there's a
whole other side of his depictions of
equal impact namely as a philanthropist
he has repeatedly been recognized as one
of the most important philanthropists in
the world with breathtaking donations to
educational programs to health and
medical research and services to
athletics and corporate wellness to the
entrepreneurial process to at-risk youth
and to conservation and wildlife
initiatives he's consistently made a
difference in ways that most of us can
hardly imagine and he continues to do so
on a daily basis so we're there for
honor to have t boone pickens as our
gordon grand fellow and we're eager to
ear to hear how this person of boundless
personal energy will help us understand
how to solve our national energy
problems please join me in welcoming
thank you
blue and I thought we'd start off by
having you talk for about five minutes
about your plan and then turn this over
to conversation because I know people
want to have a back and forth okay i'm
going to ask my daughter sitting on the
front row when i go five minutes raise
your hand will you do that for me
starting they you know you start talking
and and the subject is so important call
us and sometimes seem to go too long but
let me state the problem as I see it and
the United States is the only country in
the world without an energy plan that's
pretty sobering up there I mean can we
be that unusual without an energy plan
you'd think we had all the energy that
we needed we actually import more oil
than anybody in the world we import 13
million barrels a day use 20 million
barrels give you a reference point to
Chinese use 10 and import 5 they have
their oil security we do not so we're
importing 13 million barrels and five of
it is what I want you to focus on
tonight the other eight million barrels
comes from I think secure and safe
places friendly to us five of it comes
from OPEC and I'm convinced as Jim
Woolsey who I know it's connected he
been here lectured here I think right
yeah Kim was both of us from Oklahoma
gemena he's from the big city i'm from
the little town but Jim and I talked
about this frequently had it had a long
discussion on it this morning that the
that oil that is being paid for
primarily to the Saudis goes to the to
the country and then to the royal family
and then to the Taliban so we're paying
for both sides of the war is what it
comes out and you know
that is just it isn't smart especially
if you have resources that would cause
you not to have to do that and we do
have those resources do we have the will
to use them is the question if you go at
the problem if you look at it for 40
years the United States has never had a
plan never had an energy plan why did we
get ourselves in a spot where we're
importing two-thirds of our oil and the
two-thirds of the oil happens to be
two-thirds of our trade deficit so here
we are in a very peculiar spot and with
the with the Mideast in turmoil there in
tonight and all you don't know what
you're going to see in the morning I
have a good friend that can't sleep very
well so he watched it all night but I
get up first I want to see in the
morning what's happened in one of the
Mideast countries because I have great
concerns that the whole system could
collapse and 30 million barrels oil
comes from OPEC to the world so we if we
have a solution and I'm going to give
that to you right now if we have a
solution then we should start to
seriously consider it and take action
the solution is get on your own
resources do we have the resources we
are the largest owner of natural gas
reserves in the world because of
technology has been developed in the
last five years that we can we we have
moved from in the pack up to number one
ahead of Russia and Iran on natural gas
reserves natural gas reserves no
question is a hydrocarbon but it is it
is the better end of the hydrocarbons
it's cleaner for us it's much cheaper
it's abundant and it's ours can we use
it we sure can and I want to see natural
gas go in to transportation fuel seventy
percent of all the oil
of all the oil used every day seventy
percent of all goes into transportation
fuel so if you're going to cut off
you're going to cut off oil from what I
consider to be the enemy then go after
transportation fuel five million barrels
is what I'm after which is the OPEC oil
because so how do we do it that natural
gas I would go after the heavy-duty 18
wheelers they individually used between
20 and 30 thousand gallons of fuel a
year so go after the eight million
18-wheelers their 270 million vehicles
in America if this is successful you'll
go ahead and use it for other vehicles
too and that all come naturally but here
you want a leadership to come forth
which is president united states and i
tried very hard to get into the state of
union that by executive order that all
vehicles purchased in the future by the
federal government would be on domestic
resources not identifying anything just
domestic resources and my second step
was traction would come immediately
because the world would see something
has changed in America they're going to
this is the first shooter drop second
shoe falls 36 months and at that point
the president tells all of us Americans
not Democrats not Republicans but
Americans that we must do this he's
going to also tell us at that point that
at the nomination speech in denver in
july of 08 he said in 10 years we will
not import any oil from the Mideast he
said that that's a quote he said it
again in the fourth debate with Bob
Schieffer Bob Schieffer not had lunch
the
before that debate he said what energy
question would you ask these two
candidates if you could ask I said ask
him when we're going to quit on
importing all from the enemy and he said
that's a little bit raw I'm not sure but
he did ask about imports and Obama
answered exactly verbatim as to what he
had said at Denver in July 08 okay can
we do it back to the 18-wheelers yes
legislation will be entered on april
seventh and that will be that that to
that new vehicles would on 18 wheelers
would go from diesel to natural gas
another point one mcf of natural gas
equals seven gallons of diesel one mcf
of natural gas is four dollars seven
gallons of diesel is $25 this is an
opportunity that America cannot cannot
miss if we miss this one if we do not
take advantage of this I promise you all
of you and me included are going to go
down as the dumbest crowd that ever came
to town i'm serious we will go down in
history as the dumbest proud to have a
resource that's cleaner cheaper abundant
and ours and we use dirty oil from the
enemy that's the way we're going to look
and it's I'm serious about that that's
that will be the analysis so we're ready
to go that that bill will be entered
when will it be voted on not sure but I
think it will happen before the summer
recess and I think that we will get it
through the Senate it will be a
standalone bill in the house and I think
it will it will make it to the Senate
hopefully with very very few changes I
know you're sitting there saying Boone's
a dreamer I'm a geologist you have to be
a dreamer of your charges but I think
we'll make it through this year we will
have an energy plan for America but it
is for America it's for all of us but
you have a responsibility in this I
didn't finish
the second shoe was I don't think that
the second shoe is at the president when
he tells us that this is his plan to fix
his commitment to us in July 08 is that
this way we get off OPEC oil we've taken
care of the trucks now we're going to
take care of the individual cars that
all of us as Americans patriotic
American the next car you buy will be on
domestic fuel it will be on domestic
fuel if that happens that's where we
educate America on energy and that is
today the missing link America is not
has not been educated on energy
including Washington they do not
understand but they haven't focused
because a crisis whatever crisis said
has arisen has not hung around long
enough to cause the focus to be where
they did get acquainted with energy at
the level we should all be but that will
happen i had five kids and a five kids
you know at dinner at night can be a
mess or it can be a learning experience
or it can be whatever else there's a
crisis every night but anyway the that i
would too if I was had five kids at home
that I would assign all of them hey I'd
say look this what the president asked
us to do it's patriotic he wants us to
domestic fuel and he wants us to pick
clean fuel so let's do that as a group
and in six months we're going to go buy
a new car all of us together that will
usually get a kid's interest if they
think they're going to be a part about
in the car so that holds them in clean
they like but now that what will come
from that there will be a great
education in America on energy and
better understood when those kids go out
have their families and all that could
you may find in place that they never
bought anything in the future other than
a domestic fuel a car that was on
domestic fuel not talking about a demain
the car you don't have to buy that just
you're on domestic fuel now tonight if
you want to go out the shop for a new
natural gas passenger car you know how
many choices you have 10 hondajet civic
that will get it honda jack city in
Paris tonight if you were there and went
out shopping for a passionate car you'd
have a choice of 41 well so there are 12
million vehicles in the world today that
are on natural gas in the United States
there's a hundred and thirty four
thousand we don't look very smart that's
my five minutes he did alright so I'm
going to ask a couple questions to kick
things off but I'd invite people in the
audience to come up because the Gordon
gran is primarily designed to have
students interact with leaders i'm going
to give priority at the mics to
undergraduates and graduate students but
well then we turn onto the large
audience if needed so let me start and
but please start coming up to the mics
and don't be shy are the major US oil
companies people like Exxon Chevron
ConocoPhillips are they fully behind the
plant and if so how come they don't seem
to be more visible how can anyone how
come they're not more visible I don't
see them behind the plant I think I can
answer that with one sentence
eighty-four percent of exons revenues
come from offshore yeah Exxon is an
international company are they bad guys
no they're not they're friends money but
there they are international and they
look after the shareholders so no
they're not they're not jumping up down
to my plane because they're selling for
and all oh you've got a huge line
already so maybe we'll start right up
okay that did I fully answer the great I
think so i think it's more on their best
interest than they realize because
they're going to lose those
international supplies but they don't
quite get that yet good afternoon can
you hear me a new mystery
I have based it's a two-part question
but it's very short I know people hate
to park questions the first part what is
the role for electrification and your
plan is you see a role for electrifying
vehicles and getting vehicles more
integrated with electric grid and second
if we're going to be moving to natural
gas what is to stop us in five or 10
years from importing our natural gas
from the Middle East the way we are
other way many countries already doing a
lot of countries in the Middle East are
building the good natural gas terminals
we're already building many of them in
the east and west coasts so what's to
stop us from being dependent ten years
on that are you ready I'm sorry are you
ready yes okay I want to be sure you
were finished with the electric vehicle
it's early will it work sure to work I'm
for anything American anything American
goes on the even ethanol okay it's an
ugly baby but it's our baby it's ethanol
will work and it will be OPEC oil okay
but electric sure electric works light
duty will go to the electric as a way to
go and the final answer the final answer
that sounds a little too fine but I
won't see this conclusion I don't think
but I may see it unfolding but you're
going to use the natural gas bridge you
20-30 years out and then you will be to
the next generation and it won't be
hydrocarbons as a whale ago second
question was are we going to being
dependable yeah that we have because of
technology developed in our industry in
the United States we have a 200 year
supply of natural gas now now that will
go down of course if you switch it over
to transportation fuel but you have your
you're safe for a hundred years but all
your needs 50 and you got it covered so
it's yeah we have plenty of natural gas
we're okay on that but I'm not saying
that natural gas is going to be for
everybody that's you want what you want
to do is study the question and figure
out what is the best domestic fuel for
you
why don't we go to this site now hi you
have repeating that natural gas is a
clean and abundant fuel choice can you
address the environmental risk of
natural gas extraction especially
hydrofracking and is that environmental
risk a good trade-off for decreasing our
dependence on foreign oil tell me if I
could ask you a question that's very I
think unfriendly to answer a question
with a question but tell me your
concerns about hydrofracking they use
toxic chemicals in the process it
pollutes our drinking water because most
of the natural gas is located right by
the the drinking water aquifers
especially in the Northeast and areas
like Colorado it's basically the
drinking water that's the biggest
problem because we're obviously
dependent on that the i do not know of
any any problem with a with a freshwater
aquifer being damaged by a hydrofracking
now i personally have tracked over 3,000
wells and the first one I practice 1957
and so hydrofracking is the aquifer most
freshwater aquifers are a thousand feet
or less and the fracking it takes places
at 10,000 feet are deeper that's way too
much overburden to get tracked lids up
and into the aquifer there's not a way
to get it there now what they're
starting to do that I think most
operators are doing is they're using a
closed system so they're pumping down
fracking flowing back into the system it
loops and there's no escape of water or
frac fluids out of it and I think over
time that you're going to see that that
these questions are all answered and
everybody's going to be satisfied that
hydrofracking is not dangerous to an
aquifer do you think that using all of
that water to extract the
natural gas is a waste of another
natural resource that we should be
protecting you're talking about any
insignificant amount of water it's you
practically well with a hundred thousand
to 200,000 barrels were water and that's
that is honestly insignificant in the
aquifer that I living and I'm in the
largest aquifer in North America which
is the Ogallala and our ranches in
Roberts County that that aquifer is
200,000 barrels of water is
insignificant they extract out of there
for irrigation every year 6 million acre
feet of water so it's not a it's not a
problem
thank you opponents of renewable sources
such as wind and solar often sort of
point to the variability in the sense
that the you know the wind doesn't
always blow in the Sun doesn't always
shine to make the argument those can
never be large sources of the energy mix
in the US as understand your thoughts on
sort of those suspicions and then
secondarily your thoughts about a
domestic nuclear power in the future of
that in the mix quick on nuclear you're
going to have to use it and it's
unfortunate the accident in Japan but
obvious you should not have built the
reactors on the fault but I think
everybody sees that down and what will
happen is they'll move them inland and
away from false san clemente in
california is built on a fault that
nuclear reactor is so those you know
you're going to learn by those those
situations but you're going to need you
are your age you're going to all need
all the energy you can develop is what's
going to happen you need to understand
what you're going to deal with because
you in your lifetime you're going to see
a huge energy change you're on the edge
of a change in energy around the world
and it's the reason is you know what you
had on nuclear you know that it works
and all but what you didn't know is all
the shale gas that has been developed in
the last five years it's everywhere
you've got it in Poland you got it in
Germany you've got it Alaska it got into
Canada you've got it any place that
you've been producing oil you're going
to have shale gas because that is a
source rock that feeds the oil into the
sands and carbonates so it's got you're
going to have to deal with it you have
to understand it in all but it is all of
this is going to happen did I get the
answer there's something else to the
question oh then the renewables it's
part of the mix you've got to have it no
the Sun doesn't shine all the time and
the wind doesn't blow all the time but
what you do there that's one thing else
we've never been tasked in this country
to actually understand
and design and put our energy portfolio
together what you need and and this is
happening but not fast enough but the
wind works i'm in the wind business i'm
not in the solar business but the wind
and solar you have to have backup power
coal is not backup power for wind and
solar because it's a base load power so
what you have to have is natural gas
natural gas is is the base load I'm
excuse me is C is a backup for solar and
wind because it can come on quickly and
you can turn it off and on as a wind or
sun axe and it's but it's nothing but
design it's not anything you know that
we can't handle very easily what one add
to that that the the highest cost power
generation that you have is solar and it
costs you about six thousand of dollars
per kilowatt hour to build it 5300 a
kilowatt hour we'll get you nuclear 5000
believe it or not we'll get you cold
Colin's gone up dramatically and cost
because they have to clean it up twenty
four hundred dollars a kilowatt hour
we'll get you wind and 1500 we'll get
you natural gas so you're going to
naturally once you look at what's
available to you're going to look at the
cheapest one first and you're going to
try to build in renewables with that and
you'll try to stay away from coal if you
can but you can fifty two percent of the
power generated in the United States
every day comes from coal twenty-three
percent from natural gas and twenty
percent from from nuclear and the rest
is hydro and wind so it's just get to
know what we have available to us okay
question mr. Pickens women say I like
your Flint a lot because there's
talk with what to do with energy in the
future and a lot of them are very long
range plans how many years is something
to get back on as you said very quickly
one concern though they want to ask you
about is that I've noticed especially in
the past with energy one of the problems
you have businesses for instance oil
it's a very profitable and resource that
seemed very abundant so there really
wasn't a lot of investment in future
technologies a lot of money was
reinvested in extraction and processing
so your plan account for investing some
of the money that comes from the natural
gas and use it to research newer
technologies so now rich the gal I don't
I think that all takes care of itself ok
I don't see how I do that I don't see
how I take money out of natural gas and
tell them they've got it they've got to
give me the final product I think that I
you know I'm such a free market person
and I hate to go to the government for
anything I just how I testified for a
congressional committee and I said I've
never been at a distance 20 years ago I
said I've never been to Washington and
gone to the government ask them for
anything and immediately the first guy
that got the floor was Jimmy John Jimmy
Jones from Oklahoma Northeast District
Congressman and he said you were in my
office asking me for something yes i
said no i was there asking you not to do
something to me every time I see Jimmy
now he says not do something too that's
right Jimmy but no i don't i don't want
to go to the government to and i did so
i don't want it put back in would i be
opposed to that no i would not be
opposed to it I think the idea is sound
the money some money could do that but I
think you're going to have money that
will go in that direction here's what
will happen if i can just clarify one
thing if you again i'm so I also
free market person I I wouldn't want to
see the government's or compose that by
by a Fiat but how do you see businesses
doing this on the road you think perhaps
tax credits or other incentives or
appropriate or do you think that this is
something that's going to be completely
taken care of my business leaders
anytime you say is it going to be taken
care of by Business Leaders I mean
they're selfish motives in business
leaders we all know that and that's
subject we were on earlier today the
structure of a corporation and whites
there and everything else and the no I
wouldn't want to say that business
leaders I wouldn't want to put it all I
wouldn't want to count on them for
everything but I believe that that the
markets will take you in that direction
and you're going to have time you're
going to have time to to have a plan we
don't have a plan we have no plan it's
most incredible thing I've ever seen my
life that you have the largest transfer
of wealth in the history of mankind
going from us to people for their oil
it's incredible and we have no plan
nobody sits down and say how long can we
continue to do this I've never heard
anybody say that and so we have to have
a plan I think the things you talk about
would be discussed in that plane thank
you hey I was wondering if you could
comment about some of the hurdles to
implementing your plan that would be
posed by the past dependencies and
network dependencies on our current
reliance on oil in the transportation
sector as evidenced by just sort of
historical trends and also the
infrastructure that would need to change
to make that happen and then while
discussing that what's the
differentiated roles between the public
and private sector in unrolling that
change in infrastructure that will need
to happen to overcome those paths
dependencies okay we're speaking the
inter infrastructure question is what
I'm getting is that right okay well I
mean the things you said we're important
of course but but that's what you're
how do we get the infrastructure and
that comes that comes again I go to mop
I've said several things today several
times so I me I may say the same thing I
said to you to somebody else or I may
say it to you twice so if i do don't
laugh okay all right that the that but
the infrastructure will come with
equipment and I don't use rd have I said
this no hey I don't use rd because our
takes 10 years in D takes 10 years and
that puts me out of money so I'm 82 1010
102 okay nobody laughed I thought that
scratch that from the notes what I speak
they but they here we have the model
almost for everything we want already
has happened in the California
California has had to deal with this
problem for years that the cause of air
quality so when they got all through
they tried a lot of what answers they
came down to natural gas LAX LAX la MTA
is the largest bus fleet the United
States 2,800 buses on natural gas have
been for 20 years it cleaned up smog in
Los Angeles has a big part of the Calina
today they are cleaning up the port of
los angeles long beach because there's
on the study they made 3,500 people a
year die in that area because of air
quality and they got a guy in there
that's a tough hard-nosed green guy's
name is dave freeman and freeman went to
natural gas for eighteen thousand eight
for 16,000 18 wheelers in the port
they've got about twenty percent of them
done so you've got you've got the answer
now how did you fuel these vehicles
people make money off of
I mean it's the fueling business is a
business when I took the plan a Harry
Reid who is majority leader in the
Senate that he told me after his people
analyzing he said what you're doing
creates more jobs than anything has
crossed my desk it creates for our deal
came up with 1 million three hundred
thousand jobs is what it was for
everything trucks fueling the whole work
McKinsey & Company looked at it and said
if your assumptions are correct your
conclusions are accurate and that's it
but it what I'm talking about the
fueling will be there infrastructure
will come remember I said I wanted the
18-wheelers I didn't say I wanted your
car okay so where's the line between
what public sector regulation is needed
versus how the markets will just run
with it on their own because in the
California example you know regulation
certainly played a role in you know
incentivizing the private sector you
know transition to natural gas well they
of course they forced let me give you
another a very good move on the part of
California Southern California the South
Coast Air Quality Management District
the AQMD is powerful they've got money
in taxing authority and they got a real
smart guy running account even bury
wallerstein wallerstein had an air
quality issue he said who are my biggest
polluters they said trash trucks trash
trucks they operate 24 7 do a lot of the
idle a lot and consequent had an
inefficient burner take one of them off
the road you take off 325 cars Wow one
diesel trash truck he said ok what's the
incremental difference it costs fifty
thousand pound we have plenty of money
telling the next one they buy his
natural gas we're not buying any more
decent and we write on check for fifty
thousand now seventy-five percent of the
trash trucks Southern California are on
natural gas that program is seven years
old I think I can solve the eight
million 18-wheelers I think I could
solve that in seven years
and if we do that that's two and a half
million barrels all today and we cut
OPEC and half hey how you doing today
good that's good I'm a solar electrician
and in 2009 I personally installed about
ten percent of the residential market in
Connecticut and wave at ten percent of
how much so of the entire residential
market in the state in the state yeah is
that tell me how big that marketers we
did the company I worked for did about
it they had about a third of the
contracts and they had three trucks so
it's actually one knife so give us a
number though how many homes that was or
whatever one every week over the course
of the years about 50 okay needless to
say there's not a lot of solar projects
going on there Eden but there will be
but I'd listen I'm for you go ahead yeah
well you know I'm gonna help I'm not
trying to be I'm working together I want
to help you with your plan well why is
it so expensive if it's made out of
silicon aluminum and glass these are
three of the most abundant resources on
the planet why are they so expensive you
know you said it was a you ask when me
you know more about it and I do either i
don't know anything I've got it well we
can make it a lot cheap roof we
manufactured to mystically right you
want to do stuff domestically right I
sure do they but I mean you're getting
most I stuff in China aren't you well
why are we get here we should we should
manufacture here oh you couldn't have
lower costs this is this is a plan for
you to have a business okay oh I got a
better one how about this offshore solar
offshore solar it would be like a barge
you'd have this series of barges and
they don't have panels so listen those
are all ideas and it ends if those
thought of that yes you know one out of
ten is good so what will happen and but
you know this is what will happen this
will cause discussion and discussion
will cause activity and will solve the
problem but solar is part of the mix it
has to be so sure it's not like you
I drain the oil thing I mean can we slow
it down can we change directions is how
is that a way to watch the runaway
runaway train is like when you have this
whole big industry and you're trying to
get the automobile industry to start
accepting natural gas and all I'm not
trying to get thought about no no you
missed I'm not after that we only go
this a point ok this is worthwhile point
but no I'm not listen they're coming to
be the General Orders people we talked
two weeks ago and they came to see me
and I'm shocked they're now talking
about you know we're going to build
light duty vehicles that are going to go
for fleet operation in it and what they
came to me for is how are we fuel them
the same question we got you know 15
minutes ago how do we feel them and I
said don't worry about it so you got the
fleet the fleet I mean all they have to
do this contract or the people it pila
fueling and it's all a company I mean
like waste management the first contract
that we made I don't want to get in a
spot where I'm trying to sell you on my
product okay I'm not trying to do that
but the first deal made was in Palm
Springs California they had 60 trucks
said give us 15 of them they said okay
after long discussion 15 of them we got
it was just soon as they replaced them
they replace them with natural gas your
deal I mean you have a plan develop it
run off your costs get you a spreadsheet
work it out you may have something
that'll work you know very well okay hi
my name is Aaron Gil I'm a master's
student at the Yale School of Forestry
and environmental studies thanks for
being here I was wondering if you could
talk a little bit about the contingency
plan if the federal action that you've
suggested fails to manifest and
specifically what can local and state
governments do while we either wait for
national action or move ahead with your
objectives if national action fails to
come about it's interesting I mean at
that in it I don't know whether it's
your generation the difference that we
are I mean you're thinking how can we
get the government to help us with our
deal right and I somehow
I don't go there but I end up there you
know what I mean it's not about my first
thought now I got these it was a
Democrat governor's caucus or something
in where was it Denver yeah and we had I
don't know I member Bill Richardson was
there and then I won't try to remember
all the guys names but what all there
and I said look you guys they said what
can we do and I said just say that all
vehicles purchased by your state will be
on that ought not wrong domestic
resource start out there and just put
the pressure on your transportation
people in the state they're going to say
oh hey you know do we have to do that
yeah you have to do it that's it but
seeing in New Delhi and we talked about
this at lunch today in New Delhi they're
choking to death on diesel fumes so the
guy said whoever their leaders there
whatever he is he said we're going to
know more diesel paying you all whatever
you want to but there's no more diesel
so they went to natural gas solve the
problem I said how long did the people
complained he said all about six months
and then it was over with so there's a
little inconvenience I met with the
trucker's the 20 biggest truckers in the
United States it was a Saturday morning
before the Super Bowl on Sunday and they
were all in in Fort Worth for the game
Jimmy Haslam who has has pilot flying j
truck stop he called me and he said can
you meet with these truckers said I got
the 20 biggest truckers and can you meet
with them early Saturday morning I said
sure 330 and he said 330 what I said you
said early 3 30's early he said no I'm
not talking he said why did you say that
I said man you get the 20 biggest
truckers I'll meet with them anytime
they want to meet 3 30's fine with me he
said no it's seven-thirty i said ok well
I'll be there I came and I told him I
said listen fellas I said you have got
to be my leaders on this deal the
trucker's do
when I say that one of my biggest
leaders has been 80 Randall Stephenson
the CEO over there I talked to him for
one hour two weeks later he called me up
he said we're doing ten percent of our
84,000 vehicles on natural gas and some
of they did have some light duty on
battery but he said we're going on
domestic and but that's leadership when
they when they do that now here I am
before these 20 trucker Kevin nite nite
truck and y'all seen pick up thousands
of truck Kevin I said don't make us pay
to be patriotic and I said I'm going to
take care of with a tax credit and so if
not do that but I said I'm I want you
guys to not complain if your
inconvenience and he said okay and so we
talked it out and everything and this is
all going to happen I mean those guys
are going to be my Marines in this deal
before it's over and you'll see on the
side of these trucks where it says you
know domestic fuel you know or something
on the side I'm patriotic or something
which I want them I want them to do that
because they will lead other people see
it so what is that all about and then
they're moving the direction but I did
get those governors Oh bill Richardson
he stood up and said okay I'll tell my
state all vehicles purchased in the
future will be on domestic fuel and and
so it just it if you can just get these
you know fingers out there into the
thing and all is the key to it and then
the leadership shows up and everybody
else says you know it's all makes sense
and so did I answer did thank you good I
thank you mr. Pickens you've mentioned a
couple times today that you see
compressed natural gas as sort of a
bridge fuel in terms of viewing fueling
our national automobile fleet um you
mentioned probably 20 to 30 years but
you've also talked about how according
to your numbers at least we have
something like 200 years worth of a
supply of natural gas
so my question is what do you see as
replacing compressed natural gas as our
national fuel source for automobiles and
why and why specifically within the next
20 to 30 years I think that you I had a
discussion with Al Gore you know Alice
very green guy and I can pass a saliva
test for being green and but al gore and
I were talking at lunch if you ever go
to lunch with her without he he had
suite at the Regency Hotel New York and
he said come and have lunch with me and
I he said I said ok said I'll order for
you and and I said okay be there in 15
minutes and he said what do you want I
said whatever you eat Ali said ok do it
snob was not a bad call on my part I got
there cheeseburger with fries I wouldn't
order it but I'd sure eat it so anyway
we SAT there and I did and he we talked
about this and he I said he kept talking
about the better and said alla battery
won't move an 18-wheeler he won't do it
and he said it won't I said no and so
there that day and when we conclude we
shook hands on it I'll be for light duty
battery if you're for heavy-duty natural
gas and so the the fuels that when you
say what is it going to be they've had
to guess I'd say probably the battery is
what will be but watch out on the
battery we don't want to find ourselves
getting off of Saudi oil and ended up on
a Chinese battery I don't think that's
smart and so but I don't see the Chinese
as enemies I do see that Saudi crowd
listen when you have 18 people on two
airliners it hit two buildings in New
York City from Saudi Arabia that's not a
coincidence that's way too many from
from the item I'm an old man and I've
seen a lot of things but you know
it's I'm pretty hard to fool so what do
you want that one quick follow-up so I
guess my question that is um given given
that we have 200 years worth of natural
gas and given that it's so much cheaper
than anything else why do you think that
in 20 to 30 years we'll move on to
presumably renewably source battery
power with natural gas in abundance you
know what your say we've got plenty you
probably won't the only reasons because
somehow no question natural gas will go
up in price because go back and compare
the in one mcf for natural gas four
dollars is equal to seven gallons of
diesel which is twenty-five dollars
that's going to close up of that scale
it's going to come up on that so you
might be able to come in there with
battery that's cheaper it would be the
only way of did but it will it will come
down to which fuel is the cheapest and
if it's if it both of them are abundant
thank you want so much for being here
mr. Pickens but um well we clearly their
issues in terms of pollution associated
with the current folium technologies i
wonder if given the difficulties of
transitioning the different
infrastructure you saw a place for
technologies
to liquid converting natural gas to
standard diesel fuel okay you said
infrastructure question if you see that
as a way to alleviate that were you just
instead of redoing the transportation
feed you build plans to convert natural
gas do you feel that we get you build
watch convert convert nuts with us two
Diesel's a way of jump-starting yeah and
which you can do yes but that's more
expensive but you can take natural gas
and and go gas to liquids and and come
up with diesel fuel but it's it's it's a
way cheaper to do it and let it go it
you'll be using natural gas in two ways
you'll be used as Crescent regret and
you'll be using an lng liquefied natural
gas and on 18 wheelers a lot of those
will be on LNG thank you again mr.
Pickens I was actually fortunate enough
one stabbed in her mr. Gore briefly not
a very similar burgers stories so I like
that yeah I think you really hit the
nail on the head when you talked about
education I really you know agree with
your analogy we talked about you know a
father and mother sitting at the table
and talking to us about his or her
family about why we have this need to
transition off oil but when you look at
how deep said all of our economy is and
how you know how much oil plays a role
in every facet of our lives until we
have that change in consciousness until
we have the American public realizing
this is a collective action that we have
to take together I'm skeptical the real
change is going to occur so I'm
wondering if you could speak a little
bit more on that point of education what
you think the most important or the most
effective way to build a coalition of
Americans together for this issue and
also what you've been doing personally
with trying to recruit perhaps energy
leaders and people who are currently
that's it in the oil process to get on
board as well
I'm not at all you've left me I don't
know understand the question oh sorry my
question is what you think is the most
effective outreach you mentioned
education in terms of doing people Oh
God to come together and also at the
wheel well you see I think I'm I'm doing
what I think is the most efficient way
to do it I've got all of you together to
listen to me and i'll pick up a lot of
support out of this room and there will
be you know I want every one of you to
sign up on Pickens plan calm and that's
gotta me and 700,000 people signed up on
it so I you know I I have a plan I've
got to tell you where that came from
when I was in college at Oklahoma State
and I was initiated in the fraternity
that my father was belong to st.
eternity i did that i was being
initiated and he was a really a lot
better paternity man than i was he well
you spent a lot more time 11 he'd go on
campus hi mera we were lawrence kansas
for a football game and got on campus
he's the first thing we need to do is go
by the sae house and see the brothers I
said you serious said yes I'm serious he
goes over seas everybody talks to I
didn't do that but he was better than I
was on but anyway he pinned me that day
and the service was over and we walked
out on the front yard and he said now
it's going to get serious and I said
what's that and said your mother and I
don't think here on the same scheduled
to graduate that world I said I may not
be and he said you started out in
veterinary medicine now you switched
over to business and he said you don't
seem to be serious about anything and he
said that Sonny said I can tell you a
fool with a plan can beat a genius with
no plan
and then he he looked his Eisner down he
said your mother and I are concerned
that we have a fool with no plan I knew
it serious no kidding and so we we
hugged each other and he left but I from
that point on I have consistently I have
always had a plan I've had a plan I know
I've got something I may change it sure
that's that's okay I've adjusted and
circumstances have changed and
everything else and I'm sure but I do
start off with a plan i end up with a
plan and I've got a plan to sell this
and I've gone who you know I've gone
step by step I've got the legislation
working I'm here talking to you there
couldn't be a more influential group
than you all are that I can find and
I'll find another one and i'll talk to
them I flew 609 hours on my airplane
last year and I can tell you that's a
lot of flying and I it I had did in two
years I did 42 town hall meetings and so
I've tried and I I know the seriousness
of the issue and somehow you know I
think I got stuck with the mission is
what happened because nobody else was
willing to take it on I never served in
the service and that's unusual for our
family because there are a lot of guys a
lot of my family members who did sir I
was a little bit young for war to Korea
as my war and I was married and had a
child and I was referred and Vietnam I
was too old for that but I always you
know felt like someday I'm going to get
a mission I think I've got one I really
believe that thank you for your planet
sure so we talked about on solar and
when not always being a reliable source
what do you think the most promise
sort of large-scale energy storage plans
are like thermal star salts or on how do
we store how do we store energy like
solar and electrical what's the best
you're talking about storing electricity
yeah yeah and I don't I don't know what
I know it it's got to be solved but
right now I don't know I don't know how
you do it and that's not my field so I
can I can't give you much I gel I know
of course how you store oil because you
know you know what the SPR is asserted
Petroleum Reserve we got 750 million
barrels in that storage in the United
States and I don't want to see the
president pull that out because of
four-dollar gasoline please don't do
that that all is therefore a much
greater purpose than that if we get in a
real spot 750 million barrels is going
to come in handy but not to try to to
control the price of gasoline I don't
know the answer over then I'm sort of at
a completely different question stead of
a selling a actual cast from the US
should you total petroleum reserve what
do you thing about just selling
contracts instead what are selling
futures instead no I'm talking about
selling it for your car so it goes in a
refinery but in order to limit the price
the US could just sell a bunch of
futures oh I see don't pull with the SPR
bit but just go in the market and try do
you really want the government to get
into the marks it's just another
proposal that I've heard yeah no I don't
I don't like that answer I can tell you
if the government got into their traders
in the futures market are much smarter
than government traders
it would be very expensive whatever they
needed let's go here hi mr. Pickens in a
former life as a geologist to my
question is a lot of people say that the
best energy source that we have is the
energy that we don't use do you have any
thoughts on using technology like fuel
cells which can take the methane convert
it to hydrogen fuel and run engines at a
much much higher efficiency than
combusting the the natural gas itself
and can be used both stationary and
transportation i wonder if you had any
thoughts on that kind of technology well
what you're talking about I'm not
familiar with but I'll comment though is
it that that will work I'm sure you've
looked at it who will work what is the
reason why it's not used now it's
because it's more expensive very
expensive but um you know it does have a
lot of promise and it has about
sixty-five percent efficiency in an
engine compared to traditional diesel
engine of it all those things I'm back
to what I said an hour ago all those
things are going to be looked at and
some of them are going to be used but
we're going to know a lot more about
energy and there's so much energy that
we can conserve it's incredible I'm not
kill you I grew up in a home in in the
depression and that was a period back in
nineteen thirty but I grew up in at home
and I had a very frugal grandmother and
I I got the message real quick Sonny if
you walk out that room again and leave
that light on next month I'm going to
have you pay part of the electric field
that gets your attention I walk out of
the room today I cut off the lights and
that came when I was ten years old so we
can you cannot believe how much energy
any home I can promise you you would not
see one thing was less in your standard
of living and you cut your energy costs
by ten percent and that is HUGE if we
all cut at tendency that will come
though that'll be another program that
will come at some point I think we'll do
one more question from from the audience
I have one final one for you okay thanks
so this is in no way meant as a
criticism of your plan but I'm curious
wait a minute what is aggressive well
it's it's not a criticism but I'm
wondering um it seems to me that if we
were to suddenly stop importing OPEC oil
tomorrow that would that would very
quickly be followed by other countries
buying the buying the oil perhaps much
much more cheaply but you know
nevertheless they be buying it and it
seems that it would quickly be their
infrastructure would be developed and
they would be paying close to what we're
paying now eventually so I'm wondering
now hold it right there you know they
can adjust that by supply sure oh they
do it all the time that's what they do
that OPEC meetings sure absolutely yeah
and so they they'll they'll they'll
adjust as quick as you do sure
absolutely but I'm just saying that
they're going to find someone else to
buy the oil and we're not buying it
that's right so I'm wondering is there a
part two to the Pickens plan that
addresses the endgame well so now I
thought I gave you the end game that we
that we're going to we're going to get
on our own resource sure but are we
going to export natural gas as well I
mean I don't want I don't want to do
that but I'm afraid that's where you're
heading because you take the biggest
shale pine today is probably horn river
british columbia that is re deal is made
that's going to be transported to
kinemet bc and out to china lng to them
and the this opens up another point I
want to make but that i would like to
that guests to come south that we
actually don't need it right now but the
i would like to have a North American
Energy Alliance and from there we would
trade to control energy to ourselves to
a control what are you trying to do well
let them control something to you I mean
work with them on timber work with them
on something but we don't have any deal
makers is a problem you know anybody can
sit down and say hey look we need this
you need that let's work together and
work it out but but that doesn't happen
and so it but I think I've given
a endgame to what I'm talking about is
to get on our own resources we can do
that so but it's an acceptable outcome
in your mind that that say the Chinese
turn around and start buying you know
the five million barrels a day that
we're no longer buying from OPEC well
they're not going to buy the five
million because they don't have to go to
OPEC see David the Chinese have already
reserved their oil they you know where
they got their oil from a part of it we
spent a trillion 500 billion dollars in
Iraq lost 5,000 people had 31,000
injured and guess who got the oil
Chinese I don't the white house three
times on this subject and I said look
they should want us to have your they
said what price I said market price you
don't give them anything less than the
market so nobody could complain if the
Iraqi said for what you've done for us
if you want to call on our oil the
United States we will give that call to
you at market price I said there'd be
nobody in the world that would say well
that's a bad deal no we would have got
it we never even asked for it we didn't
get it so they put their all feels up
for bid and Chinese get two of them and
totale gets a couple we get nothing we
get nothing out of the deal and we paid
for all of it thank you thanks so my
last question is on something else you
have a passion about not energy but as I
want to show me how broad you are and
that's about your beloved Oklahoma State
football team that plays in the t boone
Pickens Stadium now last year they won
11 games which is pretty good but they
still got beat by Oklahoma and they
didn't win the big 12 is this the year
coming up is this going to be the one
let me tell you I did not read up on
this you've been so kind to ask the
question and then talk about our season
last year because we never won 11 games
before but I remember gales and when I
talked to your ad Tom last night over at
the lacrosse practice
and that when he talked i said i
remember yale had two of heisman winners
and i said one of them was named clint
something in the other was Larry Kelley
he said Clint Frank I remembered that
because my dad bought the first magazine
on football that came out in a small
town in Oklahoma he had to order it and
I was most popular kid in the
neighborhood because everybody could
come in and we can look at it together
but I still remember those Yale players
i was ten years old 1938 and so I
remember are we gonna I'm not going to
get overconfident here but we have a
very good football team and I could not
I could not believe it this year that
our quarterback and our end Justin
Blackmon in and quarterback Brandon
Weeden came back and did not go in the
draft and that that I think those guys
want to win as bad as I did and no one
wants to win as better to do it but let
me let me have two minutes to conclude
but we were interviewed the three of us
were the other day on Oklahoma City
station so here we SAT Justin and and
Brandon and I was sitting in the middle
I said fellas it what really is great
about this whole thing is that we rely
on Texas football players at Oklahoma
State we have to have them they're not
enough football players in Oakland but I
said Justin you are from ardmore where
my grandfather was methods minister and
that's Oakland and I said Brandon you're
from Edmond and I'm from holdenville I
said I like those Texas players but I
said you're the quarterback you're the
receiver and I'm the guy that pays for
everything
I said so we're we were very important
and Justin said his your grandfather
ministers mrs. church there now I said
no Justin that was 70 years ago okay I
want to thank to boone Pickens for an
amazing shirt talk thank you very much
thanks thanks
thanks fellas ha just kidding my good
sign up with me on Pickens plan calm
please